this week's videos are sponsored by
manscaped and Shopify more on them after
the reaction
[Music]
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation I am joined by
Aaron Alexander because today I have
realized every lady on the channel has
seen hairspray but not Aaron hi us two
dudes are going to watch hairspray today
out of everyone here at the channel
we're not the pairing you would expect
for hair we're not the typical
demographic but that's okay that's I
like musicals I'd like chick flicks I
don't even know if it's a chick flick I
don't know anything I know it's a
musical that's all I know well guys and
girls leave a like on this video also be
sure to subscribe click the notification
Bell because we got a lot coming out in
December thank you to prepper for
helping us head it down these highlights
thank you to all who have joined our
patreon page by becoming super sexy
reject that's where you can catch the
full length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy of
hairspray and we also cover several
things over there exclusively with
highlights and watch alongs included
Aaron you ready I was B ready to sing
and watch movies that's the intro to me
that we're going to sing during this
movie I'm maybe we should maybe we
should cover this together let get a
little
[Music]
notes where are we tell me now
Suburbia
New York is this this New Jersey oh it's
a period piece right those look like old
cars so I'm going to say yes wow what a
great opening establishing
shot ornette defies us bars I don't know
what that nword is what is that what's
that say I don't
[Laughter]
know weird I'm starting to feel my my
knees
grow
[Music]
zun ah
yes join the composition so
far okay we got style we got Moxy all
right I'm going to love this movie
[Music]
oh amen
sister baltim Baltimore that's where we
are I love the production design my
goodness the colors are
[Music]
great great symmetry too we're popping
looks like a set interesting I mean it
is a set but think it was
[Music]
intentional it's pretty
fabulous that business hates
[Laughter]
you Baltimore oh my god I've never heard
a song but it's catchy super catchy oh
that's
topical you can say
that who is this actress I don't know
I've never seen her before she also is
the
brightest outfit on the screen
everyone's like more muted around
her o get it oh you sexy lady you
[Music]
sassy
I like her walk it's got a little dance
mhm little strut to
it
[Laughter]
don't look how happy he
is let that girl ride my truck every day
that girl so
[Music]
crazy
balore a this must in a good mood yeah
this is I feel jovial this all the joy
this so
lovely Baltimore yeah you way to go
Baltimore
woo Mount Everest is the most famous but
not the highest geographical point on
this Earth who can tell me what that is
Heaven Excuse Me Miss Whimsy I can't see
the board again Tracy turn blood Tracy
turn blood if I have to write you up for
inappropriate hair height one more time
you will be removed to detention hair
can't just hang there like a dead thing
on your
cheeks bars as I said it is not Mount
Everest now next week we I feel another
song coming on I Feel It In My Bones
back approxim
60 million years now if you turn your
pages so is the music like actually from
a py psychological standpoint from
within her like she's bored it's all in
her
head I think it is nothing like we're to
see other people sing that' be
[Music]
interesting then Amanda binds Amanda
bind is in this I think that's her right
there oh
[__]
one minute to
air I've not seen Amanda bindes in Gears
oh my Efron this movie is insanely
vibrant they should have shot this on
the
volume what
look is that Christopher Walkin oh [__]
it is this a studded
cast James Mars what the hell I didn't
realize all these people W
it corny cin show teenage Baltimore oh
he is perfect for this era show are we
going to transition in Ultra
clut really
cool he is a handsome
devil man when people would congregate
around a
[Music]
television Yes
Yes Man James Marson and Zach Efron
together what what I'm sorry this is the
best movie
ever want to run that back real quick I
thought I heard it say nice white
kids what is this movie about
Harris I'm Amber Brad Tammy fenders
Brenda sketch shell you you're all good
people I guess and I'm
L he got a whole Elvis Persona this is
live television for them yeah this is
what television is like in the musical
world every single show is a musical
number my ears are garbage cans would
you turn that racket down wait a minute
yes this is the one that's
joh it's turning your brains in the mud
Mrs Tong it's a new dance oh that's cool
casting after he was in Greece now I
wonder if like on the stage if this is a
role traditionally played by a man as
well or they just cast him in this the
movie version you Penny are you trying
to tell me that that Penny didn't get
permission from her mother to be here
what
Penny Penny Penny you will never watch
that show again without that show I have
nothing having nothing
bills we will be right back for some
more of that hot Detroit
sound Michelle fer what's that the cries
of people being mugged H valma the kids
dig the rhythm and blues yeah they're
kids corny that's why we have to steer
them in the white Direction the white
Direction dude I love this uh
yeah I really didn't know any of this
was in the movie that's it's a crazy
fart this is
great good job dancing today it's
time Amber what does he have that a
ring Amber Amber save your personal life
for the camera sweetie oh shiny white
people didn't invent the
Blues
do your job my daughter wouldn't have to
fight to be visible I got to show some
of the other kids once in a while this
time next year you could be wearing an
ill-fitting tuck snapping B mitz for
photos I don't know she doesn't she
doesn't seem like a good person I don't
think she's a good
person show link this is nut she can't
even dance I can dance so much better
than
[Music]
her Queen laifa everybody's in this
movie Tuesday of this month's your
rhythm Blues day negro day will be
coming your way so don't uh uh motor go
back thank you thank you wow you think
this this movie is about
race I had no
idea I really
didn't I think it might be about race
guys seems like we'll have an opening
here on the show for a girl just as fun
loving but maybe not quite as free
wheeling cut school tomorrow and come
down to Station Wy to audition girl do
it girl make him notice you but why not
why not daning is not your future one
day you're going to own Edna's ocidental
laundry stop projecting your fears onto
your daughter you want to be famous
learn how to take blood out of car pulst
stre that's a skill you can take right
to the bank hey hey what's all this Ro
in here are they husband and wife I once
had a dream that I owned a coin operated
laundermat and I came down from that
cloud real quickly I'll tell you that
mhm you tell your daughter you don't
pick people like crazy or girls like us
oh they're talking about the size she's
projecting her fears onto her daughter
this TV thing you really want it with
all my heart then you go for it this is
American bab you got to think big to be
big big ain't the problem in his family
Wilbur nobody asked you I hope she gets
the job hope she gets it she deserves it
for a movie that has talked a lot about
in the last 10 minutes I I've only seen
like one black
person something tells me more on the
way Amber look at this moly crew oh this
town sh has gone downhill since I was
Crown Miss Baltimore crabs my God how
times have changed these girls must be
blind or completely dur God I love
Michelle Fifer when
Baltimore Amber that move is far too
dirty mother wake up from that dream of
yours this isn't
1930 that former star she's like a
Disney princess Disney villain princess
oh totally I'm trying to say Disney
villain
poor might still hold
some screwed
Judes see what you got twist twist twist
twist mashed potato Momo on my show
you'll never find a thrusting hip or
bumping gr what's that a dance for fleas
and ticks oh you should have seen my bag
of tricks God they're [__]
[Music]
Baltimore the costumes are to die for so
bright and vibrant are you scared we're
on live no I'm sure I can call well this
show isn't broadcasting
cinemascope this one will never never
get a date in those hand me- down
clothes kid she'll never get a date till
daddy buys her new nose
OU would you swim in an integrated pool
I sure would I'm all for integration
it's the new
frontier First Impressions can be tough
and when I saw you I knew it if your
size weren't enough your last answer
just blew it
ouch so and stout you'll never be in
we're kicking you out per form and your
face this poor girl dang she's just
getting roasted over here you may go
umow thank
you poor girl I think they secretly
liked you there she goes that's a
[Music]
line she's still optimistic though still
perky she is cutting my class Tracy
turnblad I trust it was something really
important I'll give her a break it
should have been
gave her
detention what' I
say what' I say I called it
black now this movie starting what you
looking at nothing not you damn come on
girl that's how I respond every time Aon
walks through that
door now you don't
what does that dance a name oh this call
it the pton place after midnight I use
it to attract uh the opposite set it's
working that is so
groovy spin spin my man yes use those
hips kind of like
this hey hey oh [__] oh oh girl get it
oh oh girl hey I know where I've seen
you before where corny show on negro day
negro day is the best I wish every day
were negro
day yeah yeah hello my name is
sewe she's getting
real what's yours baby she's vibing I'm
Trey
turn yeah she's found her
people are you one of
us
let's
go
hey get
[Music]
it I have no idea who this actress is
she's insanely charismatic she's really
great what's the ideas of March I mean
how can a month have an idea hold on
come
on is he a commentary on Elvis
culturally
appropriating
what she doing with the
Negroes Aaron you can't oh you you
can't I'm used to telling everyone else
that
here Cor in the Hop tomorrow but if he
saw you dancing like that he'd put you
on the show oh yeah oh W sorry little
darling hope I didn't Venture do we're
watching High School Musical next
Sor yeah this must be like mid 2000s he
still looks like teen Efron well don't
you hear him chime chime's not exactly
how I'd put it you feel my
heartbeat whoa we're we're in 1950s
Baltimore you be careful about the
touching my uned when he tapped me and
knocked me off my feet oh is he is he an
actual high school student he's in this
High School
Musical
Bricks
now
he's like wow something about you
homie now he's going to start sing about
her cuz she she touched him they're all
smok walking a buch of
[Music]
smoke the driver's
instructor I really feel like it's
storyboarded like that had to really
compose this film
he mothers C but I
see oh
God that was very sexual he was just
greasing his hair with his tongue real
slow like that's all the greasers did
[Music]
it oh man you got to be with that that
black
guy he was dry
he can't move like
that he already got a girl well clearly
things aren't going well between
[Music]
them y what's with the divided lines in
the pulse I don't know it's like uh
almost like it's like whites and colored
or something like that oh you got to
separate them okay yeah
yeah it's like
laundry okay I'll go in front of you and
it's not about race it's just
about products oh my God is she going to
defeat racism in this movie I think she
is she's going to bridge the gap want to
do pton place for corny you got to dance
with your CR and I got to dance with
mine why it's just the way it is Tracy
but it's your dance is she so unaware of
the
racism she touched a black
man time to get a bunch of attention
yeah girl go hips
[Music]
oh he can't take his eyes off her oh
he's getting turned on oh yeah we're all
getting turned on that boy frecked
up oh
yeah this
is this
is Dam how expensive was this movie
235 million
why are we watching
thisy
Mike where
isor and I'm
yay what a way to own oh my God she's
the full center of attention yeah she
changed her hair too and we just got to
get black people on television tell us
about yourself well I watch the corny
Collin show and I do absolutely nothing
else we to think I almost stopped her
from reaching for the stars now here she
is on local daytime
TV and if you were president Tracy what
would your first official act be I'd
make everyday negro
day what did she say dude we should get
a shirt that says that what negro day
make every day every day negro day
yeah reject shop Nation
[Laughter]
I want that chubby communist girl off
the show let me be the first to toss the
Harpoon ouch first we get rid of negro
day finally some sense out of you and we
mix those kids in with the rest of the
council
oo isn't this where it's all hidden
anyway now you can fight it or you can
rock out to it you can monetize it get
some chocolate chips in the cookie try
face W cushion good choice wow she's a
product
already oh at his
[Music]
shop it's been a long time since I've
seen a pure musical where where it's
like most of it is the musical yeah very
long time yeah I can agree I think the
last one I saw was in the Heights that
was a couple years ago that big little
girl is sending my sails through the
roof more people are breathing aerosol
than oxygen think you could show ooh
it's the fifth it's fine just like
smoking in rooms is
[Music]
fine oh my God it's
begun oh my God they're just so much
better
dancers oh sorry sorry I mess I missed
you I'm
sorry I'm in a weird leg position
sir that's what we're talking about
they're just much better
dancers if I could take my brain and put
it in their
body God that' be unstoppable there got
to be some program out you need to get
[Laughter]
out
oh let's go what I like about
you
damn okay oh Wonder she' be liing out of
Lollipop all day we'll be right back
with more negro day brought to you by
Napa away for stubborn hair damn every
Kink will be gone in a
blank the
back oh how dare you pick the same song
they wrote it you watch yourself wow you
are one inch from being canell you know
what your demographic is cleaning ladies
and Lawn jockeys ah just go in a ditch
somewhere hello is this the turn
residence yes Jerry Sandler Stiller I
get I get Ben and Adam mixed up all the
time you're
racist you want Tracy to do what be a
spokes girl be a spokes girl I think
she'd be perfect tell me I get a free
Captain perks like Captain have to be
negotiated maybe we should get you an
agent what voice is he doing Tracy I
haven't left this house in in years why
we'll have your father meet with him I I
don't want to be seen like this SE one
I'll do it after my next diet that's
when I'll do it you see the neighbors
haven't seen me since I was a size 10 a
ma it's changing out there you'll like
it people who are different their time
is coming that's
righty
she's a revolutionist
[Music]
Aon she's plus-size and not a racist
she's a revolutionary she's a Pioneer
even I haven't this house since
[Music]
a
You're So
Glamorous pregnant women smoking and
drinking that's right that's
progress that it's like a satire of the
time too it really feels like they took
advantage of translating a musical to
film just the amount of different
locations they do and the amount of
different sets they have oh yeah no they
they definitely translated it very well
in a way that feels I don't know it it
it captures the stage Essence but you
know it it lives in the world of film as
well it's very well done very nice is
this your older sister oh my perhaps
you'd like some complimentary cure now
if you'll just sign here no don't do it
no I want a non-exclusive contract and I
want you to absorb my 15% commission not
a dime over 10 throw aier do you have
any idea what this
I forgot I was
asking what accent she he's doing
[Music]
balmorian you got to do B
atut at us where is there a team that's
Happ that's fabulous I let go go go of
the past now that joll does have a
blast it's like the
show
[Music]
a this look like it' be so much fun to
film yeah
[Music]
man
yay wait till Dad sees you sees me
he never notices what I'll wear in 20
years he never even said to me nice Mumu
or nothing wow really think she's going
to run into somebody she knows and then
she's going to get all self-conscious
and go back inside this is Amber and Mrs
vont tussle Mrs vont tussle is the
station's manager oh damn John F to
Michelle Fifer that's cool let me guess
Randy dress yes well you'll stop traffic
oh screw you dude that is cruel you're
awful don't you know why she hates us
she's afraid I'll be Amber from his
teenage hairspray
really anybody can get grass stains all
over their
back Amber stop it I'm sick of you doing
that just because she's a good dancer
I'm sorry you think that she can dance
we know she can dance what is going on
back there Tracy that's horrible Mr
Flack does not have breasts I would I
would never so proud of herself perhaps
you like to share with the rest of the
class Patrick Henry's Immortal Last
Words kiss my
[Laughter]
ass you go you go be with them yes learn
some Rhythm so the black people are
always in detention I guess
[Laughter]
so not quite
huh you put there for the littlest
things I guess having a platter party
tonight y'all want to come check it out
now would you mind if I to checked it
out she's also in detention well would
it be safe you know for us calm down
cracker boy what was that expression
Zach Arron just
made
[Music]
yeah but always have
the yeah get it damn who is this guy
he's I no idea
[Music]
too this is why you guys keep going to
attention cuz you just leave i s they're
in detention cuz they're always
[Laughter]
[Music]
dancing I can't wait to buy this
soundtrack or illegally download it
whichever one just like streaming on
[Laughter]
[Music]
Spotify
yo this dude's a real star of this
[Music]
movie this guy's the
best and that is how she
died honey reeling him back in is the
easiest thing in the world now don't
worry mommy will take care of
everything it's got like a Krill devill
thing about her does she oh totally
she'd make a great K DeVille old evil
Hollywood Starlet mhm conquering
[Music]
Baltimore That's The Equalizer right
there
Aon the one and only there are no other
actors who go by that title looks like
y'all took a step out of bounds mama
wants you to meet my new friends this is
just so
afrotastic you go girl I relate so much
with
her my name is Mike Mike yes Mike Mike
who what the stuff dog what the hell
right now as we speak your daughter has
entered a hotbed of moral turpentine
what that I don't know I mean in trouble
with someone else maybe it's worth it I
think no one use the start of a pretty
big adventure Tracy edner turnblad just
don't say anything about People's race I
mean you don't have to rush off you know
what I do I'll left my iron on oh your
AR what I I can't get over that voice
Aron on to
[Music]
eat come on girl you know that sh look
good just dive head first come on is
that
[Music]
Brae is the proper terminology soul food
yes Greg it's soul food good okay that's
what I've cre food you had chitlins
[Laughter]
[Music]
Greg how come in movies it's it's always
the black people who are so welcoming to
the white people that the white people
are always like black that's not the way
real life
Works
[Applause]
[Music]
y
I'm glad Amanda binds is here she's
participating she is there to look at
things I got something for you yeah it's
just in you're going to love it
oh cigarette oh it [__] cigarettes
that's nice what can I do you for
something for the mister sadly there is
no Mister at the moment be careful she's
dangerous I do need a fella the way to a
man's heart is through his his Funny
Bone now here's a ice breaker for
you but what are you celebrating well
it's kind of an ending but it deserved
to go out with a bang what are we
talking about the cutting you from the
show all right time y'all new how did
that end off screen we have had our last
shows our little show is a nice little
placeholder the colored peoples it
wasn't getting ratings bull now I'll
never get a chance to be on the show oh
and you will be seen baby Zack AF must
be so comfortable right
now TR black and white say never dance
on TV together if we can't dance maybe
we should just March nah let's dance I
like the way you turn black Tracy 11:00
new what yall say slowly but sure should
we give this fine woman all great and
she
deserves let's March are lovely people
but if you protest you'll be on lists
you'll be un filed J Kover will be still
wi tapping your cold dead body in the
grave dude I mean what would you do say
what would I do if like the ones to
March Yeah March bro you getting March
you know marching march with us what if
they fire me from Scream
seven if they fire you then I would quit
because I have other obligations just
promised I could sing at Miss Hairspray
Pageant she invited agents that's my
shot tra I can't jeopardize that you son
of a [__] I just think this adventure
is too big for me oh God no no no no
that's not right I get it you're a baby
he just called her huge he called her
obese to her face he hates her because
of her because of her size she hates her
size and he hates black people confirmed
she's crazy about you you have to say
that you're mother well I know a little
something about
me
wa those lips those eyes
that oh my God it's a Grace
[Music]
crossover do you think he really
wouldn't cheat on his wife with her I
think he's trying he's either extremely
oblivious or he's loyal as
hell maybe
both your wife Ma you don't really
believe this he would do you never set
him foot on that show again wow the plan
worked he didn't even do nothing damn
it's not
fair it's not fair Tracy you know these
peers have never looked at another woman
This Heart only beats for size 60 60 wow
and then to just cancel negro day like
that just to make sure that nobody who's
different she watch it again except but
every time they say negro they would
take a shot
okay I like
that people like me are going to have to
get up off their father's laps and go
out there and fight for it if there's
something you need to stand up for don't
you listen to old dogs like us
Christopher Walkin is always good to
right in the line between creepy and
sweet and
endearing like Gary Bucy
no
not
quite like John
[Laughter]
Mal she just makes me feel old nonsense
D yes Styles keep a changing the worlds
rearranging but Edna You're Timeless to
me a you're like a fatal disease babe
but there's no cure Sol at this fever
rage it's the classic walking dance CZ
when I need a lift time brings a gift
another day you you wouldn't expect him
to be a great singer but he is he's
killing I don't know if I've seen him
seen in anything else before you seen
him seen before mhm I can't stop eating
your hairlines receding and soon you'll
have nothing at all this is a story
about acceptance Aaron it's
beautiful
love and breaking the mold you'll
never they sing their way in Proms and
sing their way to Solutions sing your
way to Solutions sing your way out of
phobias what a beautiful world we're
going to sing our way out of racism
too oh hell yes yeah looking
[Music]
Foxy look at the different eras yeah
this is pretty
cool their Love Is Timeless and Spanish
and
Spanish you'll always be first string
You're Timeless to me I like how the
song they chose for them matches sort of
like the period Association yeah it's
very classic more classic yeah with them
and to call it Timeless with these
veteran actors wake up everything's good
again wiber what
happened you going to pay a heavy price
I know never dance on TV again if I
can't dance with seaweed and little ANZ
then I don't want to dance on TV at all
this girl just has such a good heart I
know I sto relating with her she's too
[Music]
perfect oh was a nice song Get It Queen
cuz I know where
I you lead the March you lead the March
lead
[Music]
him where's Amanda binds looking a
lollipop right
[Music]
now integration not segregation TV is
black and white equalizer let our
children Dan Queen Latifa is The
Equalizer
baby God damn the pipes God I had no
idea Queen Latifa could sing like
this
I I love the how they kept this one
simple how it was just a March like it
wasn't like a bunch of choreography and
everything oh no let you absorb the the
song itself yeah stood on its own but I
don't get what the point of the song is
to be honest with
you I know they're just saying words I
don't know I was like they're not
dancing so I'm
bored just kind of went over my head I
don't
know she went to pull out her daughter
and now she's at the front of the line
by accident
you it's
police learn to March properly I got I
got
us good good job got us covered man
don't
worry you and your little friends head
back to where you come from what do you
mean little excuse me she was talking to
you Tracy no don't do that all right
boys let's take the whole lot
in you're kind of
[Music]
outnumbered just a bad in in the merch
you're going to leave right leave let
all your other girl black friends take
the fall for you maybe she's going to
get a Gatlin gun a Gatlin gun yeah yeah
that'll solve it Miss turnblad brutally
attacked a sergeant with a blunt
instrument you see she going from turn
black to turn back I'm so sorry I'm
proud of you you are baby somebody had
to do something these two are so
sweet bail for 20 is kind of pricey you
bailed all those people out upset with
me what do you mean those
people you could go to jail for helping
me Tracy I'm already in jail come on
already in jail H it's poignant we get
the collard greens we could do some
vegan mac and cheese that would be great
maybe you could live down here I don't
even know why we have this room down
here but there's food water first aid
kit oh my God the police are on their
way things need to change and I won't
stop trying to change them good you'll
be waiting 20 to life get the jump rope
P don't you touch my can
tuna lock in the safe bunker I hope a
missile drops on Baltimore right now I
hope she goes for the can tuna
first yeah maybe it's her it's the
police Oh I thought you'd be Tracy a
fron I was just at home uh practicing my
new Twist on the twist I overheard it on
the news I can't believe Tracy savagely
bludgeoned an eagle
scout I should have been there beside
her I can't sleep I can't eat did you
hear that teenage
hairspray you are absolutely positively
permanently punished you will never
leave this room again I hope she gets at
least one song in this movie you think
she's religious in real
life hey just the man we're looking for
I'm here to rescue the fair made
baby know while she's up this is
hot myself on the outside I looked
[Music]
good I hope he just keeps finding more
food all half
eaten
she's into the knives okay
confirmed
[Music]
she
girl that's right that's my greatest
fear that's my
[Laughter]
[Music]
wife's yeah damn he's really passionate
in the way he like kisses her and stuff
and everything as it should
[Music]
be music all over is
awesome I love when they keep the comedy
[Music]
going she like what the is going on in
my record store why you ain't think of
that before what you think she done for
us where your man is at boy I don't know
I don't know got a girlfriend and now
shut up you Oh So This is Love What is
love baby it don't hurt me you two
better brace yourselves for a whole lot
of ugly coming at you from a NeverEnding
parade of stupid so you met my
mom how insanely subdude manes in this
she's so so passive oh yeah she's
literally the support character in every
I need every way of the word turn your
face this way the other way everybody oh
my God teenage hairspray p is about to
begin I once saw Amanda bin in person
though yeah yeah instead of what I like
about
you so it's a story about getting black
people people on TV and self acceptance
we're getting the world to accept you
too the agents are
here they look like Secret Service
agents there's no sign of her we're on
every door she's not inside doesn't mean
she won't try valma I seriously doubt
this girl is going to risk incarceration
to win a pageant you don't know her you
don't know this
[Applause]
girl that's a lot of hairspray how are
you breathing right now I used to use
hairspray did you really W I don't like
the way it feels I feel like it's you
know for just something tells me it's
just not good for
you just I don't
know are they spraying real hairspray
yeah oh Jesus and now for the talent
portion of our competition our counet in
their Miss teenage hairspray official
dance
off oh ouch
damn
[Music]
they just need to throw a bunch of black
people on that stage don't they they're
hidden in the audience launch them in
them like like
t-shirts confirmed sighting what you
[Music]
drink it's a distraction Aon it's a
distraction oh my God what if she's
already in the building what what if
she's been here for hours that's one
more Point
[Laughter]
Greg a giant hairspray
bottle put your back in it then put your
backs in it this time sneak
faster that's right Christopher it's
with you people I mean how hard is it to
beat down a door that hairspray
battering ram was heavy heavy how could
it be heavy they're inside of
it uh wow what a crazy crazy plan you
got to get her you got to depend on them
using the hairspray bottle to break down
the door got to admire the creativity
that's like some Lex Luther [__] right
there some Baron Zemo [__] some some Lex
Luther BBS Ultimate Edition
[Music]
[__] I so
unimpressed
but even if Tracy wi she'll still go to
jail for beating the [__] out of that
police officer true maybe they'll be so
inspired she'll be acquitted of all
charges or she'll sing her way out of an
arrest so how we resolve conflict in
this movie the final
tally it is my obligation to announce
that Amber Von tuss is about to get out
dance Tracy turnl look how excited he
was she get rid of the be
[Music]
yeah
Tracy he's in love with
her
yeah Proclaim Your
[Music]
Love ah yes
yes
you savior
them you white
save Efron use white
[Laughter]
[Music]
save oh
damn damn these two turned me on so much
the sexual chemistry is
crazy I really feel like they're really
attracted to each other oh
yeah people believe the most must have
happened all set with
these that's
[Music]
real
wow yes break the and the new this hair
spray
is that was cool that was unexpected she
deserve
[Music]
that they defeated racism yes one dance
number at a time see I told you what's
the point of marching you have to dance
you have to dance she's not even a
candidate she just got a Title Wave of
calls Velma well anyone who dances for
it is eligible rule 30 paragraph 5 estri
down at the B
[Music]
okay oh oh oh she got oh ttch it twitch
who's twitch the dancer who was like
he's huge he's big on Tik Tok So You
Think You Can Dance he I'll tell you
later I'll tell you about it later I
switch the damn tallies
small you're uncanny
camera oh my God can't see her face
she's so white bir do it now or forever
wish you
get on
[Music]
there
wow I Ro just so embraced the [__] out
of this I love it so much Corney do
something the show is turning to gumbo
damn straight is turning to gumbo this
is the future that's right that's
this is your
time the activate white
safe D what an epic finale God
damn I can learn this choreography I
believe in you you can't stop the I
already know
it to my
[Laughter]
blood
woo cut away immediately okay they're
back no you need at least 6 months to
get over your
[Laughter]
ex-girlfriend you can do that now with
better
[Applause]
help is it over yeah it's over directed
and choreographed by the same person
I've ever seen that before W that's cool
Leslie Dixon dude we defeated racism we
did and uh
um obes ISM obesity and racism in one
movie Let's
Go I need to wash my hands that's
okay how lovely that was really lovely
that was really lovely you know what's
even more lovely though what's more
lovely Greg when when companies want to
support the the
Channel when you're likely to not have
your video monetized due to the amount
of music that plays in a
video thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us empowers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
their are war-winning support always
there to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team Mary
bsmith reject Nation you know what the
funny thing is I already owned this
product before agreeing to do this
partnership I could have used my
influencer ring to get it for free right
at a discount but hey now you can get it
at a discount cuz this week we are of
course sponsored by manscaped as a
married man who's always on the move I
value looking sharp all keeping things
efficient that's where manscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in
featuring the lawnmower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a
perfect gift for yourself or for another
man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out
of my own pocket but no seriously this
is easily the best because it comes with
not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good thing I have
two now for demonstration purposes so
you got the standard trimmer for a
perfect neat trim but this one the new
foil blade for that super smooth finish
and oh yeah it's all about safe grouping
with their Advanced Skin safe technology
plus they're waterproof so no more
crumbs on the carpet the package also
encloses a WeedWacker 2.0 for ear and
nose and I definitely use this because
look at me I'm a hairy guy and the must
have liquid formations the crop sother
aftershave lotion and the crop preserver
ball deodorant say goodbye to poet of
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate Cher on top two free gifts
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
[__] 2.0 toiletry bag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing my here
right now and the bag is perfect for all
your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming
game head to manscape.com and use code
rejects for a cool 20% off plus free
shipping remember it's rejects for 20%
off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls holiday ready with manscape
okay so we got the credits rolling Aaron
please my friend who I did not
intentionally bring
here because he's
black a racial mie we almost watched
city of God which would have been way
more on the nose I think I don't know
anything about it um I saw I think I saw
black people in the the cover the cover
I don't even know what that movie is I
don't know what it is either but I was
like n let's watch
hairspray and I'm sure this will be a
nice fun time wow with no social
commentary
whatsoever uh I enjoyed this movie it
was fun it was a lot of fun the the
music was catchy the dancing was
incredible the sets were awesome all the
acting was really good the lead girl is
super
Charming everybody just [__] freaking
killed it I can't say the FW maybe at
this point in the video I can but uh
yeah I thoroughly enjoyed it I thought
that there's such diversity in the types
of music we saw in the movie I thought
the performance especially I think it I
guess Fray credits it was an ' 80s movie
first and then a a stage play in 2002
really yeah just by the order of what
the credit said oh fascinating okay oh I
would have thought this came out in like
um came out like the mid 2000s this
version of it anyway oh yeah I thought
this this play came out in 1962 exactly
huh no
wait oh no it came out in the 80s you
said the movie came came apparently
there was an ' 80s
movie you would have thought it came out
in the 60s I me said I'm just
joking I was saying that I thought the
the stage play would have come
first that would makees sense but uh I
guess not maybe okay maybe they made the
movie then the movie inspired the play
and then it's one of those situations
where the play version inspired the new
iteration of the movie right right right
right right that could be a thing okay
that happens sometimes let's watch the
original one now let's do it back to
back compare compare back Tob back I
mean like this is the exact same movie
there's not a creative bone in this
movie spot but this time we're taking
shots every time they say negro day oh
yeah and I'll chant it three times every
time I can get away with it and I'll
give you a look which you don't know if
it's approval or disapproval but I mean
look yeah that's just a fear in me it's
okay it's how I respond it's okay you
either gain a lot of respect or get a
lot of haters either
way um but what you not like about it uh
only two things only two things but
doesn't take away from the rest of the
review I think that there are moments I
think just a causality of like just
musicals in general where there were
like moments or beats that were like
skipped over for the sake of the plot
like for the the fact that uh they
didn't they got cancelled or their negro
day got canceled off screen we didn't
even see like the process of that and
then uh there's one other thing that
that happened off screen that I was like
oh this has happened a little fast um
well I get what you're getting out
because things get resolved quickly very
quickly like there'll be a moment of
tension or conflict and then resolution
can kind of come the time it was the
most prolonged was the whole thing with
um the cancellation I can't say the word
right you say black day it's a black day
African American day what about g day
Monarch says that referring to Godzilla
nope that sounds offensive in some now
say end day
say they say any
day they they cancelled uh the the black
people's day there you go you can say
that but I really want to say the
word I'll pay you money you
let me say it man my hostile moment
right
here it's like 50 cents for
everything yeah but no yeah I I think
yeah this the causality of of it being a
musical because there uh they want to
make this this experience that's both
fun that has this plot carry the music
that they're trying to do but in that
some of the character moments uh both
plot-wise
as far as like how they progress and
individual character moments are kind of
sacrificed because of that I think
that's just the causality of just the
kind of story we're watching but overall
I enjoyed it I had a lot of fun with it
I can't say it's my favorite musical but
it's definitely a really enjoyable one
there's like a number of songs I can
think of like Baltimore was really great
the You Can't Stop the Beat at the end
was really great um who's that guy you
said was there twitch so he was a dancer
he's like a really famous dancer uh that
he was on like So You Think You Can
Dance he was like really big with his
family on uh on what's the app the clock
app Tik Tok and uh yeah he was like he
like did a lot of stuff for like the
community for like younger dancers and
stuff and then either I think it was
either late last year or early this year
uh he kind of unived himself so oh did
he yeah yeah yeah it was a big thing um
but um yeah he's a really good guy he's
really uh positive and really impactful
on uh both ansers and just like young
black people yeah yeah he was a good guy
but it was cool to see him pop up in
this movie I I liked his little Cameo uh
but yeah man I I I liked it overall man
what you think I liked it quite a bit uh
I thought it was really fun
and I I obviously have no idea what the
80s version is like or the 2000 simp I
have no had no idea what this movie was
even about um I expected a period piece
just due to some of the images that I
had seen and I really I thought it was
like some of things just going to be a
little repetitive from what we said
during the reaction vibrant colorful um
full of charming Charisma just laced her
out every performer gave their aame even
for someone like Amanda bind she really
knew her role just like there's
something so funny about how simple of a
character she is like it's it's not like
um I don't want to I want to make sure I
phrase this properly cuz I don't want it
to sound like I'm justifying something
here cuz it's not to me I feel like it
was super intentional of how her
character like just this like completely
kind of Airhead
dry um type of performance that I
thought was really really funny and and
uh but yeah our main our main character
lead was uh amazing as well John TR vure
too joh great yeah took me a while to
get lost in it like I I would be I was
really aware almost every time they cut
back to John Travolta that it was John
Travolta oh yeah I never I don't think I
ever stopped seeing John Travolta I was
just like okay I accepted that this is
John Travolta playing this mother and
he's like I think that's part of the fun
though yeah is like knowing it's John
Travolta that's like you you need a bit
of that awareness like you you never
stop seeing his face but I feel like he
does a good job with his mannerisms of
portraying that this is a woman who's
like a recluse who has like a lot of
fear and uh and well I self not
deprecation what's the word um
insecurities yeah I think what helps is
he's so committed to it and not in a way
that's like I'm playing the joke of I'm
a guy in a in a in a in a big suit and
I'm a woman you know he's not like Eddie
Murphy and it or something you know he's
he's just really committed to the car
and because of his commitment uh even if
you're like even if you still see John
cholta it works yeah like within the
context of the film so I thought he was
great I think I I think Michelle feifer
was very effective as the villain of the
movie I thought she was excellent the
costumes were gorgeous and the
choreography it's it's fun to see a
musical where a lot of the
times what I really liked about it was
that it felt like a film you know and
and granted it's like based off of a
it's a remake of a 80s movie but what I
what I really loved is you know seeing
that it was directed and choreographed
by the same person uh was really
interesting to me
because this could have easily been
something where it relies so much on
just the performances and the
choreography yeah but the movie's really
directed like there's so many shots in
this film and the editing is kind of FL
Flawless and the way they capture the
musical sequences there's such great
variety of musical numbers and uh I I
was I was so impressed by just how
composed every musical number was that
it wasn't just relying on performers
singing and dancing and getting a few
shots like there was so much effort put
into directing the [__] out of this
movie you know and and I love that and
you get this like really cathartic epic
finale but I do I would I would agree
with you though that like yeah I mean
it's it's long uh it feels long you know
and maybe we're more aware of the time
just because of the kind of day we've
had but you know so it's under two hours
technically but yeah yeah you start to
feel a little bit towards the end yeah
but but when you do get to finale you're
like this is a really great finale it's
fun I was there was never a moment where
wasn't wasn't enjoying that final song
but I did find myself kind of craving a
bit more I guess the word is like
sitting with the tension and really
feeling it at times instead of like
getting result because it took a while
for like tension to really kick in it
was like a 40 minute Mark and and I
think you kind of need some of that like
the actual main plot to feel some of the
drama you know and let some of those
moments breathe a little bit more yeah
but it's musical so you're often getting
swept up in musical numbers and maybe
that's not where you're really going to
get like my favorite kind of musicals
are are the ones that that can be um uh
go in and out that can really go in and
out a little bit more often and and
really experience the drama of the
scenes when there's not a musical number
happening do you see a tick Tick boom I
have not that's a great I've heard
that's a great musical yeah yeah um I
haven't seen that one but uh as it
stands I mean I think it's a pretty gr
it's a grandiose It's a grand Larger
than Life film and you know the message
is pretty uh simple don't be racist
don't be racist don't be a Prejudice
towards people of of other body
sizes I did like that because we've seen
a lot of movies there's a lot of movies
out there about like defeating racism
and while that's a message that for some
reason needs to constantly be driven
home to even to this day uh to when
dealing with body images in the same
movie I'm like oh that's actually
something I've never even really thought
about it Ander to be like who you put on
TV right and and to be accepting of that
and to embrace all types uh I thought
was a
really really really neat thing to do
like a duel of of both of those actually
in one movie yeah I thought it was
interesting because it started off about
her about uh Tracy and her uh being
perceived as not being worthy to be
someone on TV because of her body size
and then there were there were like the
the seeds planted in about negro day
like in the beginning and felt like it
was going to be her overcoming this this
whole journey of like how she's
perceived in the world and how that
affects her generally oh they made a a
musical too I mean a a live version
interesting uh but yeah then it it
turned into this larger thing of
inclusion not only with people of
altering body sizes but of race as well
and I think once we got to see the
aspects of race that's when like the
thing really like kind of carried off
and I think if we would have gotten a
little bit more moments to breathe or a
little bit more of the tension of that
kind of like how you were saying I think
it would have been like a heightened
experience but I think maybe that's just
how the musical is on its own but yeah
like I thought that that number where
they were all walking through the street
was really good you know it wasn't
really about the dances about the
performance it was about this moment
this this act that they're doing in
solid day or one another because they
are experiencing an injustice so yeah
yeah also the the variety of music was
really great from the music number
musical number we saw with uh m not
Michelle Fifer what's her name Britney
Snow not Britney Snow did you say
Britney Snow is that is that who it was
no the the classic song with Christopher
Walkin and with uh John jolta and that
song versus like the more traditional
kind of stuff with Baltimore that like
feels like very Musical theery and then
we had uh the song where they're walking
through the street that feels like very
Just Like Old School very very much
rooted in in Black Culture and and uh go
Queen Latifa song Queen Latifa was also
great in the movie as well I thought she
absolutely murdered her performance and
I also like the satire like there's a
lot satire yeah satire yeah there's some
good satire in it there was a great
satire when they make fun of the 60s I
thought that was really fun the I like
the scene where um it's it's what's her
name's number it's a John tr's number
and she's going out and like the
exaggerated like there all the kids in
the car and then like the the pregnant
ladies what you were talking cuz I first
thought that's what you were talking
about so that's what made me remember
that was that the movie has really funny
satire yeah no it's it hey this this rot
and tomatoes has now also as I've been
wanted to compare the rot and tomatoes
both both the movies have incredible
audience in critic scor the the 2007
that's when this came out 2007 yeah um
but yeah like the Eddie Murphy
comparison someone else also said that
he attempts at a fat female it's gone
wow someone said when Blonsky dances
it's embarrassing that's really mean she
was like the best part of the movie boo
who is that that black guy Amanda bindes
was into cuz he great he was excellent
Superstar I'm
surpris I have a theory that the the
main girl she's so charismatic and such
a life and such energy in this movie I
have a feeling she's more of a theater
actress and they got someone from the
stage he' be the lead of the that would
make a lot more sense Elijah
Kelly Elijah I feel like he's probably a
theater actor too okay let's see what
has she been in so far a lot it's uh
IMDb the chick oh I guess yeah this are
movies right here huh not a ton I have
no idea what any of this what a huge gap
between 2023 in 2013 she didn't do
anything for like 10 years I guess one
thing in
2017 Dam mag
TV all right let's look up Elijah Kelly
I feel like a lot of these guys are um
theater actors yeah yeah oh he was in
the butler I haven't seen the butler
I've never seen the butler either what
oh dude that's perfect
for for us as as just friends yeah as
friends as buddies as just friends
nothing nothing
else nothing reason we'll wear our negro
Day t-shirts to the movie does that have
to do does that have to do with black
people what
blind people
black I think so you ever seen Ray you
want to watch the movie Ray with uh with
Jamie Fox the Ray Charles yeah Ray
Charles I know that movie really well
they taught me that racism exists yeah
you haven't seen it I have seen it it's
a great movie we should watch it again
I'll watch you watching the movie okay
yeah what about Roots seen
Roots uh no I have not seen roots I
haven't seen Roots either that be a fun
one that sounds like a really fun
reaction right there oh jeno and chained
you watch jeno and chained of course
have you not no I love that movie it's
one of my favorite movies all time dude
you got be so excited I was like Now's
the Time
views remember seen the Kill Bills
though yeah I had someone for you and
they done messed it up oh they watched
them
lame boo hre Gordon oh now he's stuck
with just watching Jewish movies movies
here gosh dang
it
anyway Jackie Brown never seen Jackie
Brown oh that has a black person it does
there a few of
them there's a couple in there
actually hey man sometimes you make
enough of these racist satire jokes and
people are like that's funny and then
once in a while people will just come at
you happen to day did it really on some
old ass video of mine that I saw a
comment on what yeah from years ago they
were like that was I know you think
you're funny but that was kind of racist
and I'm like hey man law of
averages it's funny and then once in a
while like whoa that sounds racist you
made like hundreds of videos you still
just got get alert for all the people
that comment on your videos yeah it was
some patreon video oh okay so it might
have been really
bad wof cuz I could be more edgy there I
kind of want to see it now I didn't even
click on
it I want know what you
said oh what were we going to say about
this they said they said like I'm Asian
and that's like and I know you think
you're funny but that's kind of that's
racist but if you makeing like an asan
you can get a pass because you're asan
and that's what I said I said like this
is an old video and I'm Asian that's all
I said there you go you get the pass
yeah so I'm like what's up that's that's
selflove right there how dare they yeah
how dare they presuming now let me tell
you a black joke lady is what I
you oh you're G to tell me that
Christopher Watkin uh sang He's sanging
something you didn't ever see that music
I actually don't know if he sings in it
but there was that music video it was
like a really famous one I was worried
it was going to be like a famous movie
that I never knew about I don't actually
I've like seen stuff of him singing I
was always aware but now I couldn't even
call the hand uh I couldn't even okay
there was one like famous M The Fat Boy
Slim one is a huge is a huge one where
he's just it's just him dancing the
whole time what is this I've never heard
of that before you've never seen the Fat
Boy Slim one no I've never heard that
it's great it's just him dancing that's
awesome he's got like a I I was aware
that he has like a theater background so
that's I think I just knew that he sings
oh for sure and I've like heard like
bits but I didn't I can't tell you like
yeah he he sings This and That 72
million views dude no it's just like
it's a great video I've seen it a bunch
it's just him dancing the whole
time
just Christopher walking dancing for
three three minutes and 45 seconds it's
a really good video clearly the man's
got it the man's got the skill um but
yeah in this movie overall hairspray I
would give it like um I just think for
like the amount of creativity and from
what I can see from the raw and tomatoes
comparisons it's not just a shot for
shot remake or I think they even create
some songs for it oh wow um from what I
can see and it's and it's funny too the
movie is funny it's really funny it's
fun and I think the movie the movie
movie when it Embraces the com I think
there's some very creative visual gags
in here yeah and when they Embrace that
I think it's really effective so while
like while the message is nice I wasn't
like super moved by the message or
something I'm more like this is a fun
movie fun songs and with great
performances uh I I think just for film
making like that was really I give it
like a like a n out of 10 Ju Just for
that uh alone give the film the film
making or the film n out of 10 I think
think my overall film experience is like
an eight out of 10 okay um I probably go
7.5 okay yeah yeah but I I I boost it up
because I'm like this took a lot of I
think I think there's a lot of
creativity in this movie and and I give
it for the credit and knowing just how
long
it having a a basic understanding of it
takes forever to set up one shot yeah
and then to see just how much Ingenuity
they put into like every every single
scene where it didn't feel like a mess
it still flowed the entire time in a
smooth way I was I was delighted by that
but yeah there was something a bit
missing for me so yeah I've seen other
mov musicals that have moved me never
had that like that heart like wrenching
or that that heart grabbing number
within the movie you know I think they
they for the most part kept it like on
the lighter side with their with their
stuff but yeah I do agree with you in
the sense that it was like a movie you
tell that was directed really well and
like the shots look like they're really
well composed and like the way that the
they shot the music just felt very
energetic the whole movie felt alive
like you can tell a movie where like
it's just very static and they don't
care but they really you can really tell
the love and care put into this film
both within the performances and behind
the scenes so yeah I would say overall
was a 7.5 because it didn't I feel like
the the themes they touched on both with
the stuff with like the weight and the
food and the black experience I think
something I can identify with personally
but I think for both of those things
being in this movie it could have hit
harder me what crazy who would have
thought uh but yeah I thought fight with
the white people that's right uh I yeah
give it a 7.5 and yeah it was fun a good
time yeah man uh what did you guys think
of hairspray what's your favorite
musical number here what's your favorite
musical leave your thoughts down below
um be sure to subscribe leave a like and
uh hey we'll catch you all soon peace
out reject Nation peace out peace
[Music]
out